hello everyone I've been getting a lot
of requests to show a game by Sharma dro
and I never seem to get around to it
but here it is this is Shakti of Miami
tiara versus art team of f I was played
in 2004 it was the third Aeroflot open
Festival and I was played in Moscow
Russia and it's I checked a couple of
games and this one seemed like the most
appropriate one the official name of the
game and chess games is the loan shark
like the loan shark but as this chakra
are it's the loan shark although I don't
really enjoy this name so if any of you
have a suggestion for this name I will
change the title of the video if you if
you have a nice suggestion for me so
let's see this game shark is the white
and timofeyev is black we have d4 d5 c4
e6 Knight to c3 c6 the Queen gambit
declined
we have III Knight to f6 Knight to f3
Knight B to d7 Queen to c2 so the main
line of the semi Slav b6 with Bishop to
d3 Bishop to be 7 to both sides just
developing where castles and Bishop to
e7 and here we have e for what can push
you for a4 so he does we have D captures
on e4 Knight captures on e4 Knight
captures on e4 Bishop captures on d4 and
Knight to f6 and the black is very much
ok with this as he did manage to develop
all of his pieces he's ready to go rook
c8 c5 and well he is pretty much fully
developed and also castle and in this
position
mama D I replayed the Knights to e5 he's
attacking this c6 pawn twice and well
black has a look has a number of options
here for example I myself would capture
this bishop here on e4 without even
thinking about it you know if I can grab
a white light square Bishop I'm gonna
grab it but well the team if I played
rook the c8 here but it's it's
interesting to check what happens if
Queen captures on d4 if Queen captures
sorry if Queen captures on d4 this
simplifies the position a bit too much
in White's favor after Bishop captures
in c6 check Bishop captures on c6 Knight
captures on c6 now with an attack on the
Queen and the bishop on e7 and for
example Queen to d6 Knight captures on
e7 Queen captures on e7 and well after
b3 white will enjoy this position much
more than black after this Bishop
assumes this beautiful diagonal so after
this Knight to e5 move team FF did not
capture this Bishop although although
it's it's it's perfectly fine move if
you played rook to see it defending his
c6 pawn we have rook to d1 and now he
captures Knight to e4 and Queen captures
on e4 team fair castles and Bishop to f4
is played and well white the black
definitely wants to push c5 at some at
some moment which is impossible for the
time being as well the bishop would be
hanging from the Queen and forth so
Bishop the a8 is first played and now c5
is is is an idea we have worked to d3
this well prepares plenty of options for
white he can double up on the D file you
can go rook g3 rocketry
it all depends what will be needed so we
have c5 attacking the Queen now from the
bishop on a 8
we have Quinta III and Queen the e8 he's
moving the Queen away from this rook
x-raying her also preparing ideas like
Queen to c6 if the knight ever moves
maybe maybe Queen to a4 or or well it
all depends on what white will play but
white plays d5 we have a capture Sundy
5c capture Sundy 5 and now c4 and ok
discount we'll attempt on the rook and
this becomes a very powerful pawn after
black gets in Muslim for example I could
be 5 B 4 and C 3 this could be really
dangerous for white so he plays rook D
to D 1 and we have Bishop to d6 now
attacking this Knight Queen to g3 is
played and we have Queen to b5
and in this position we'll probably best
for timofeeva would have been to capture
this night here on e5 but he decided to
go for a queen to b5 attacking this b2
point but this allows mummy-ji out of a
very nice tactic he plays Knight to c6
and well this opens up a discovery to
this bishop on d6 and well you can't
really capture this night because Bishop
captures and e6 now wins the exchange
because now the light square bishop is
attacked
so after this Knight to c6 move he had
to play Bishop captures on f4 but first
now there's there's an intermezzo Knight
to e7 check we have King to h8 and only
now recapturing so Queen captures on f4
and we have Roxy to d8 now getting the
rock out of harm's way it was attacked
by the night and also well attacking
this d5 pawn we have rook to Ditu and
protecting this B to pawn and also may
be preparing to double up on the d5 we
have Quintus e5 and now d6 and rook to
d7 black is preparing to double his
rooks as well on the D file to add more
pressure to this d6 pawn we have roped
the c1 we have b5 like really black
would really enjoy playing before in c3
although this is impossible for the time
being we have worked the c3 like I said
before it's impossible as c4 would be
captured immediately and here team of
five plays with rook F to d8 and now he
has a triple attack on this pawn on d6
and well shah mahmud arrow doesn't
really care to defend this point as he
finds a very interesting idea he plays
rook to e3 and already you can see that
this King on e h8 is feeling very lonely
there as he does have some weaknesses on
the back a back rank so this is the
question can black capture this pawn on
d6 well the truth is f6 here would be
the most the best move as it would
create some you know some space for the
black King so he can use it but
timofeyev didn't really see a shark side
yes
we played rock characters and v6 and
here comes my Rose idea he plays the
Knight to g6 with Czech and this is well
it's a very nice move is it it's a
triple Knight sacrifice Black has three
options how to capture the night you can
play rook captures night F captures
knight or H captures night so let's see
if rook captures night if rook captures
night you get a rook captures and the
eight with the check and when we move
Queen f8 and rook captures an FA this is
checkmate
but after Knight to g6 check you can
also play F captures on g6 and this
would have probably been been the best
idea but after H captures on g6 you get
Queen captures and e6 and white is
winning here Quinn captors and e6 and
rook captures and v6 and the black
cannot recapture this rook as he gets
well Rob t8 checkmate so he would simply
be down down the exchange and well
losing the game so only other option
left after Knight to g6 is obviously H
captures ng six and this is what team F
played he played H gets worse than g6
and I invite you in this position do try
and find maderos idea here it's quite an
interesting one
I'll give it a couple of seconds if you
want to try for ourselves okay for those
of you who saw the idea congratulations
and for the rest of you who just want to
enjoy the game I'm Yara played Queen to
h4 check and well but you can either
cover up with a queen Queen to h5 or he
can play King to g8 unfortunately King
to g8 doesn't work after King to g8 you
get Queen captures and e8 with Czech
rock capture screen and rook captures
and yet now again with Czech and after
King to 87 rope to h3 is completely
winning only move Queen to h5 rook
captures G captures and ro captures an e
8 and well what has a rockand black
doesn't this is self-explanatory so
after Queen Queen to h4 check a team of
F tried Queen to h5 and well this allows
Mahmud Yadav to finish the game with a
great style
he plays Queen captures on the 8 with
Czech and the idea is rook
after sandy a rookie after sandy age
with check King 2h7
and now I'm sure everyone can see it
it's rook rook e8 and well whatever
black plays loses the game white is
threatening rook to h8 checkmate and
only way to stop this is for example g5
so black can go to GE black King can go
to g6 or King to h6 so he can go to g5
but whatever he plays simply rook to h8
check and after King to g6 grabbing the
Queen and well this is completely
winning if black grabs the rock rook
revs on a8 again completely winning and
well black doesn't really have a better
move if he if he moves the bishop wife
will move the rook and again completing
winning position so yeah very very nice
very nice game by shock damage Arab it
was in this position actually that
opportunity move every sign in the game
I do hope you enjoyed it and like I said
if you have a suggestion this is the
final the final position if you have a
nice suggestion for a name for this game
do suggest it and I will change the
title of the video so yeah I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon